welcome back to a20 special relativity
in the previous section we have seen how
we can look at energy and momentum of
particles in a decay here we now want to
in collisions of particles create new
particles
the example the first example here is
the collision of two protons to create a
proton a neutron and a charged pile
the masses are given there so the
question now is
what is the minimal energy needed
in order for this pro process to occur
in a fixed target experiment
fixed target experiment is we have a
accelerated proton and another proton at
rest this might just be a hydrogen
target just sitting there so the
question is how much energy how much do
we have to accelerate the proton for
this process to be possible
now
again stop the video and try to work
this out
the
important part here is
um to realize that minimal energy here
means that
after the decay all the decay after the
process occurred all the new particles
need to be addressed that is the that is
when the process uh requires minimal
energy so instead of analyzing this in
the laboratory frame we want to analyze
this in the center of mass frame right
the momentum has to be conserved in this
in this discussion so there needs to be
some sort of momentum but in the center
of mass frame that's not required so in
that frame the momentum of all outgoing
particles can be zero
and that's how we start the discussion
here so in this f prime frame here s
prime is the center of mass frame the
energy the minimal energy required is
two times
the mass of the proton times
gamma so here those two protons are
colliding
with the velocity and that's an equal to
the energy after this process
c squared times the sum of the masses
some the mass of the proton the neutron
and the charged pile and then you just
have to solve this for for gamma to find
gamma equal to 1.08
or better in this frame of 0.37
note this is the gamma
where this relativistic gamma or the
velocity better of the protons two
protons in the center of mass so we're
not quite there yet with our answer the
answer then needs to be boosted back
into the laboratory frame and we have
seen how we can do this for for better
work velocities in general we find
better in the laboratory frame is two
times
or just result or 0.37
over 1 plus 0.37 squared which is 0.65
that velocity we can then take and
calculate the gamma factor of the proton
in the fixed target exponent
all right so we analyze the situation in
the center of mass frame and then the
launch transformation by just looking at
the velocity into the fixed target frame
so this means now numerically that
the proton colliding with the proton at
rest
has a total energy of this one proton of
gamma m naught c square which is 0.32
times
938 mav
overseas
mav
and so that results in
1.1.238 geb
but we're interested in the kinetic
energy
so the kinetic energy here is given by
gamma minus 1 m not c squared which is
300 mev so we have to accelerate the
proton to 300 mev
in order to be able to have this
process to occur
all right very similar problem now but
here we want to produce antimatter so we
have a process of
proton plus proton
into three protons and an antiproton
charge is conserved and in the initial
state the charge was two in the final
state the charge was two as well
okay
this works very similar as in the
previous problem but what we want to do
here is compare the fixed target with
symmetric collisions okay so again the
question is what is the minimal energy
needed in order to produce anti-protons
in proton protein collisions
okay so following exactly following the
same procedure as before
in the center of mass energy the energy
is two times the mass of the proton
since gamma times c square and that's
four times the mass of the proton
okay gamma prime so the gamma factor in
the center of mass frame is two better
as 0.75 and then we just do the very
same thing again we calculate the
velocity in the fixed target frame and
we find the velocity of beta of 0.96
and gamma of 3.57
so if we compare this now
we need a pair of 1gb remember gamma
minus 1 is the kinetic energy protons in
a collider experiment or
2.57 gv protons in a fixed target
experiment
okay so you see that
in fixed target experiment in order to
produce new particles the energy has to
be much larger a factor of 2.5 here in
this example than a colliding experiment
and that explains why
we use collider experiments in order to
test the energy frontier to
produce the largest possible energies
and the lhc is one examples where we
have proton proton collisions in a
circular ring where those protons are
brought together in symmetrical
conditions
you